of more than 500 book critics across the
country they'll present their prizes at
an awards ceremony in new york city on
march 13th you can find the complete
listing of nominees at salon.com
lost history tells the story of
reporters who broke the secret contra
operation in iran
author and journalist robert perry was
assigned to report that incident which
came to be known as iran contra
during his talk mr perry explains how
similar stories went underreported by
the media during the 1980s
in particular he mentions nicaraguan
cocaine trafficking and the guatemalan
genocide of mayan indians
mr perry was at a bookstore in
washington d.c for this hour-long
presentation
good afternoon everyone thank you for
coming out today
we're very delighted to have robert
parry back with us again
to talk about his book
um
the this is it lost history
and it's about the contras
and uh
going back into history and discussing
uh
what were the some of the secrets around
the activity of the united states
in nicaragua
and why the united states took such a
great interest in
the in in helping the contras
so um
bob is a magazine editor and he is
uh they are revamping a magazine which
they are calling american dispatches
and it will be on the newsstand in
perhaps a week
a week or so and you can get it at
politics and pros
so um we're glad to have you with us
today
well thank you look forward to
this oh i forgot to say i'm carla cohen
i'm one of the owners of politics and
prose and i welcome you all here today
well thank you carla for that
introduction um
and thanks for turning out on a saturday
afternoon here
um
perhaps one of the first questions
people might ask about uh my new book
lost history
is why i would want to go back and look
at this
difficult period of american history the
um the period around the uh the contra
war in nicaragua and that is sort of the
focus of the book although it does go
off in
uh other directions and talks about
what's happened to the american news
media
uh and is is more current in that sense
uh but
uh it's my feeling that the that the war
in in nicaragua that was fought in the
1980s uh was an important moment in our
history
uh one in which uh the united states
government took a very aggressive
position
uh
supporting a an insurgency force the
contras to overthrow leftist government
in nicaragua the sandinistas
the
the one of the problems with the war
however
was that the contras were involved in
some
very unsavory activities
uh
the most notable um that in terms of the
controversies that have swirled around
them
was the problem of
nick of contra drug trafficking
and this has been an issue that has
lingered really since the mid 1980s
and has never been dealt with
with the
with the degree of honesty and
thoroughness that it should have
because when the united states engages
in an activity of this sort
um and then tries to cover up some of
the consequences
it says something about the relationship
between the american people and and and
the government as well as the american
people and their press corps
because the american public counts on
the on the press court just to a great
degree
to inform them and alert them about
problems of this kind
and the way the press handled it this
issue
is almost equally troubling to the to
the actual problem itself
but perhaps i should just start by going
back to the beginning of this war and
showing what we now know
there's a great deal now that's on the
public record
but there's a great deal that the
american people have not really been
told about this public record
we now know based on
the on testimony that was given to the
united states senate
as well as investigations done by the
central intelligence agency itself
that the problems of the contras and
drug trafficking went back to the very
beginnings of that operation
back even before ronald reagan became
president
according to testimony by an argentine
intelligence officer leonardo sanchez
reese given to the
to a senate investigation
and kept secret
uh the
the real problem begins
in 1980
at a time when the argentine government
is controlled by a
a right-wing military force which has
been engaged in a dirty war itself
the argentines saw their role though in
fighting communism as going beyond
simply dealing with their own internal
leftist problem
they they saw their role as being part
of an international effort
to go after leftists and dissidents
around the region and really around the
world
in 1980 they also became involved with
a an effort to have a coup d'etat in
bolivia
the bolivian government at that time was
democratically left elected somewhat
left of center
and the and and there were efforts to
overthrow it by the um by the bolivian
military
and the bolivian military was working in
collaboration at that point with the
roberto suarez uh drug cartel soares is
one of the original
uh drug lords in south america in terms
of the cocaine trafficking problem that
was just really beginning just being to
take shape at that point
and we and from the testimony of
leonardo sanchez reese who was an
argentine intelligence officer involved
in these operations moving their money
uh we we now know that the that suarez
provided roughly 30 million dollars
that was going to be used to overthrow
the government of bolivia
and it was there was there was a very
bloody
uh coup d'etat which became known as the
cocaine coup because it put in charge of
bolivia effectively uh
a group of drug-connected
uh military officers and they
essentially held power for two years
but sanchez reese also says that as part
of this this 30 million dollars in
laundered drug money
some of that went to support
in paramilitary operations in central
america including the beginnings of the
contra operation and as we know the
argentines moved from bolivia
where they helped support that coup
on to honduras where they helped set up
the contras
so what we now know in terms of the
record as as as this argentine officer
put it forward
is that
the contras really where were conceived
in in
in the money from the drug trade
and it went on from there
the sanchez reese operation in bolivia
became the source of raw coca which was
then delivered to um
to a a growing uh or
then a beginning small business cartel
called the medellin cartel
which used that as a supply of coca for
development of the trade to the united
states
which became one of the principal
sources of cocaine that was coming into
the united states at the time
so these connections go back very early
we also know that uh now based uh from
what the central intelligence agency
reported uh in a in a report uh la in
the fall of 1998
that the
uh that the that the that there was also
connections between
the contras cuban americans supporting
the contras and the medellin cartel
and that those operations go back also
very early into the contra war back into
the early 80s
now as this as this was taking shape
uh the
in the united states there were some
complaints about from congress and and
from public interest groups about the
contras there were concerns about
them engaging in human rights violations
uh and there was a there was a battle
inside congress about whether or not the
funding should continue
while the focus at the in those early
and early period was on questions about
international law and
human rights violations there was always
this thread of that at least internally
now inside the u.s government of concern
about some of the people the united
states was engaged with
uh we now know based on the on the
documents that have come forward that
the cia knew way before we did
in in the washington press corps
that that this was a serious problem
uh they were finding things out but not
of course making them public
at the time i was with the associated
press
and i be i was covering uh intelligence
activities
uh and as it turned out the the the
contra war in central america
and that led us to stumble into a number
of the problems that the contras were
having as we were reporting on their
activities
i did a story about
about some manuals that the cia prepared
for the contras uh on how to conduct
sabotage inside nicaragua and one that
was interpreted as an assassin
assassination manual
uh as well while with the ap
i also began working with brian barger
who was hired by the ap to help out in
this on this project
and and brian had very excellent
contacts with the uh mercenary community
that was working with the contras so he
provided additional sourcing uh from
from really the ground in central
america and in miami
and many of my sources were more focused
here in washington
but one of brian's sources um began to
indicate that he was aware of a problem
with drug trafficking an issue we really
didn't want to hear about we were having
enough trouble trying to cover the
stories as they were developing we're at
that point working on um
on the activities of a fellow who wasn't
that well known at that time his name
was oliver north and and i'd written a
story back in 1985 very sketchy story
about
norse
activities inside the white house trying
to secretly keep the contra war going
despite the congressional opposition
but when we went down to uh to pursue
some of those stories we also learned
about more and more about this drug
trafficking problem
so uh brian and i wrote the first story
in the in december of 1985 about the
counter drug activity
the us government flatly denied that our
story was true the state department said
there was no evidence to support our
our assertions in the ap story
and we went on from there facing this
increasing effort to try to stop us from
doing those those articles
and and much of the much of the other
washington press corps
felt that there may not be as much to it
as we did
i'm not sure if their sourcing was weak
or if they just didn't want to get into
it but it it was something that we were
learning about in greater and greater
detail as we went forward our stories
also stirred senator john kerry in
massachusetts to begin his own
investigation
of the contra drug problem and other
criminal activities by the congress and
he began to learn more and more
throughout this period though the the
reagan administration kept insisting
there was nothing to it
uh
kerry uh faced opposition
within the executive branch when he
asked for information
uh we now know the ci was learning a
great deal at this time
and contrary to the contrary to the
assertions of the administration that
there was no evidence of this they were
in fact developing enormous amounts of
evidence and they knew far more than we
did that this was this was a serious
problem they knew for instance that
among the cuban americans who were
working with the contras
one of one of the individuals felipe
vidal was working directly for the
central intelligence agency and the
agency knew that he was involved with a
drug money laundering operation and also
smuggling operation down in costa rica
called frigerificos de puntarenas
there was another cuban-american
involved in that operation named moises
nunez
he was working directly for the national
security council
and when the cia interviewed him in 1987
as these stories kept bubbling forward
this he told the cia that he could not
talk about his his drug activity because
it involved work he was doing for the
national security council
so we had this problem that was directly
into the white house
at that point the highest levels of the
us government the cia interestingly when
after uh nunez told them this
they decided not to ask any more
questions about it because their
responsibility was to check on the cia's
involvement with drug activity and since
nunes was working for the national
security council they felt it was not
worth pursuing
but they continued then to hold back
other information as congress was asking
what the story was with some of these
individuals who were being named in
press accounts repeatedly
the uh the ci said we that they knew
nothing
they've now since admitted uh more than
a decade later that they actually had a
great deal of evidence and information
about these these folks so we had here a
case where the u s government
at the highest levels was protecting
these kinds of drug operatives
the cia has also admitted now that it
was aware of uh investigations that were
underway in san francisco and elsewhere
where the cia went to the prosecutors
and said don't pursue these lines of
inquiry
because they might be politically
embarrassing to us
and there was a case called the
so-called so-called frogman case in san
francisco involving a number of uh
drug operatives who brought uh cocaine
uh into the bay area through
by boat and through um
by having people dress up like frogmen
and swim it in
that the cia decided that this was a
case that could very well have
implicated the costa rican front of the
contra war so
they they they they told the prosecutor
in um
in in san francisco to not pursue it and
he agreed
so we had actual cases now of of
where the cia was obstructing
investigations
into this drug trafficking
we also had cases where the with the us
government knew that these problems
existed at the very highest levels
yet the effort was always to contain the
story and the reason the reagan
administration wanted to contain it so
much was because it was trying to get
congress to resume aid to the contras
during this period and obviously
this kind of information would have been
highly uh disadvantageous to that effort
so we had we had a situation where
the the contra war was then refunded
in 1986
but the iran contra scandal broke and so
the administration then became concerned
that if this additional evidence came
out it could lead to the impeachment of
president reagan
so we saw a strong effort across the
board to contain this material
uh and as this one went through what one
of the allies that the reagan
administration found surprisingly i
suppose to some was much of the
washington press corps
well there were cases where the
associated press
cbs news and a few other organizations
did pursue these stories the new york
times the washington post and other
major news organizations
went the other way they began to dismiss
the evidence dismiss the witnesses uh
claim that there wasn't really anything
here
uh the new york times in particular
wrote stories about
how the witnesses were all uh convicted
drug traffickers
or that they never said anything about
this problem until after the iran contra
scandal broke
both were not true
the uh the fact is that we had written
our first story at the ap in the in the
fall of 1985
almost a year before the iran contra
scandal broke
and many of the witnesses were not
were not drug traffickers some were dea
officers some were people who'd been
working with the contras and were not
involved in legal troubles
in the united states but those kinds of
stories helped contain this scandal
and pretty much the scandal went under
wraps
the
the congress did not pursue it during
the iran contra investigation it was
left to senator kerry to work on
senator kerry did go forward with
hearings under tremendous pressure to
stop them
those hearings produced a good deal of
supportive evidence
senator kerry discovered that that four
of the groups that had been hired by the
united states government to work with
the contras
were also implicated in drug trafficking
so he had evidence and and but again the
the washington press corps decided to
downplay it
when his report came out in 1989
it was essentially buried on the back
pages
uh dismissed and almost ridiculed
and that's pretty much where the story
rested
there it did it flared up again in 1990
and 91 after the invasion of panama and
the arrest of emmanuel noriega and his
trial
um obviously the united states had
worked closely with noriega during the
contra war
and and then later arrested him for drug
trafficking
and and when he was put on trial the us
government actually brought forward some
of the same witnesses which testified
before kerry and had been dismissed as
not being credible and they put them on
to testify against noriega on drug
trafficking allegations as credible
so we had this sort of strange
dichotomy where on one side a witness
who talked about noriega in one setting
was was telling the truth about drug
trafficking but when he mentioned the
contras his evidence was dismissed
and this is pretty much where it all
rested
until 1996
and that was when a reporter out in san
francisco gary webb of the san jose
mercury news
decided he would do a story based on
some information from a case out there
regarding how the contra some of the
contra cocaine had gotten into the crack
epidemic
and his story had some flaws in some
ways perhaps it was a bit overstated in
different areas and he didn't perhaps
put all the background in he could but
the story was essentially on target
and it represented a serious threat to
the to the washington press corps
which had pretty much dismissed this for
a number of years
so the way the washington press corps
then responded to it was interesting
first they tried to ignore it
uh but it was picked up on the internet
quite a bit
the uh congressional black caucus
made a big issue out of it uh black
americans really across the country were
furious over this possibility that that
the cia and the us government had in
some way helped the crack epidemic move
forward
so after a brief time the washington
press corps then decided to attack
gary webb in his story and did so quite
aggressively
the contra drug story had never appeared
on the front page of the washington post
until it was written up as in in the
context of attacking gary webb for
writing about it
the new york times did pretty much the
same thing uh the la times followed suit
as well
and interestingly all those stories
would say somewhere if you read them far
enough that
that oh everyone knew about the contra
drug trafficking was an old story back
from the 1980s and there was some truth
to it but not what gary webb was saying
that became the official position of the
washington press corps
now
the problem was that the ci agreed to
investigate and as did the justice
department and they began looking back
into this issue
the um
and the cia did a fairly honest job uh
inspector general frederick hits
went back and collected much of this
evidence
and began piecing it together into a
report actually a two volume report the
first volume dealt with the california
issue which gary webb had raised
and was and basically said that
that web had overstated some points
but that there were problems and
the inspector general recounts the
effort by the cia to stop the the san
francisco drug investigation for
instance
uh so
on the record we now knew that there was
this effort by the cia which had always
been denied as having existed
we also knew
that that a that a
a letter had been written
by the attorney general attorney general
smith in 1982 at the request of cia
director william casey
that protected the cia from any
requirement
from reporting
on drug trafficking by its uh by its
operatives the so-called letter of a
memo of understanding
and in this
there is clear indication that the cia
did not want to be called on to report
this problem
at that time in the in that period of
1982.
obviously it wasn't just the contras
that they may have been concerned about
there were problems with the afghan
rebels as well in terms of their
involvement with the heroin trade
but the cia was given
permission by the justice department not
to pursue any of this
but we also then find out further when
the justice department comes out with a
separate report and then later when
there's a volume two of the cia report
and these reports provide even more
detail more damning evidence that
there'd been a long-standing effort to
contain
these allegations
and that dea officials in central
america were being
stopped from looking into problems
uh and
and that that there had been a real
effort to protect
the people doing the drug trafficking
and when the agency learned that there
were people that it was working with
involved in the drug trade they
protected them and kept that information
from congress and the american public
so we get to the end of the story
in 1998 and
with this report coming out
and the cia posted the report on october
8th 1998 on its website
and i've been covering the story for a
long time i thought it was very
important to sort of
to be to get it out to
read what was reported there and and do
a story about it
and i thought there'd be a lot of
competition because finally the cia was
coming out with this remarkable document
uh perhaps one of the most remarkable
documents ever produced by any us
government agency
but there was no competition really to
do that story the new york times did a
brief brief piece a couple days later uh
inside the paper did not go into the
details of what was being disclosed
uh the washington post didn't write
anything for almost a month
the la times never wrote anything about
the report after it was written after it
was released
and so the american people never got to
understand what had happened
uh in this very serious moment of our
history when the u.s government let
itself become involved with
some very unsavory operatives
the press basically joined in the
cover-up
so one of the purposes of the book lost
history is to sort of go back and try to
establish this record the idea of lost
history is that that these these are
facts that are on the public record
they're in black and white
the problem is that the american public
has not been given this information in
any coherent way
which has been a real failure of the of
the washington press corps
and the book also deals uh with how that
happened what was the changes that
occurred in the washington press corps
during this period the pressure it was
under in the 1980s not to pursue these
kinds of stories
but the but the overall point is
that the american people really deserve
to know
what their government did even in
difficult times even when the government
was acting improperly
and that this idea that these things can
be sort of swept under the rug when
they're as serious as the us governments
being involved in criminal activity
is something that that really should not
be allowed to go forward
so the book is an effort to say to that
that the american people have a right to
know
and that
that this is a way to bring that all
together and present it to them
and we thank you very much
[Applause]
you want to have questions of course any
questions yes
uh motivation of the cuban american
community being involved uh back in the
80s was it political tried to bring down
the the
um
sandinistas
uh or was it a profit motive for their
own anti-castro activities or well i
think it was a combination of things the
the the cuban american community
obviously has a very strong feeling
about about communism about uh
revolutionary movements because they
they were on the losing side in cuba
and the uh
and having become involved with the cia
during the bay of pigs era back in the
early 60s there was this tie into the
u.s intelligence community that was very
strong
the the cuban americans
in some cases obviously not many but in
a limited area did become involved in
drug trafficking as well
and that became an embarrassment for
this for the us government and the cia
for some time because many of its
operatives in the cuban-american
community
were later implicated in drug
trafficking uh and when those people
went into the contra movement to help
out the contras
it was partly i think
ideological and uh and philosophical
but it was also a business opportunity
because it was many of those cuban
americans who were involved in the drug
trade who in going down to central
america
brought their business with them
and they found that the that using the
cover of the contra war
protected them
uh from uh us investigation and possibly
prosecution
uh and we now know the people like uh
felipe vidal and and luizes nunez who
are described in the cia report
as being involved in this business
um
were were they were cuban americans who
had who found a joint opportunity here
you had cases also of uh of a man named
frank castro who was described in the in
the agency's report as being essentially
the contrast tie-in to the uh to the
medellin cartel
the um
and and frank castro
was had had a history of drug
trafficking and the us government was
concerned when he became that involved
but it didn't really stop him because
this this importance politically of the
country war was so great
that in all these cases the white house
turned the other way
and and let it go forward rather than
blow the whistle on their operatives
yes sir
my name is david martin and i think
you've really um
hit the nail on the head when you you
say that the real problem is with our
press or their honesty with their
thoroughness
um
and uh and that the press joined in the
cover-up but i think you isolate your
argument i've looked at your book
um i voted for bill clinton back in 1992
because i wanted to get rid of the
corruption and
and uh and then i look at your website
and i
i read this you wrote in april 17 1999
between senator faircloth and some other
conservatives were promoting wild
suspicions that vince foster had been
murdered
on february 26 1999
but richard mellenscape chastised star
for failing to prove some of the wilder
clinton conspiracy theories
such as dark suspicions about the
suicide of deputy white house
councilmance in foster on december 5th
1998 you wrote some conservatives were
pushing vague conspiracy theories about
foster's murder
about four years ago our mutual friend i
don't know if he's a friend of yours a
friend of mine ernest fitzgerald
a pentagon whistleblower gave me your
name and phone number and said because i
had i went to college with vincent
foster i'm very interested in the case
and i i was digging out lots of things
and it was going in the drawer because
nobody talked to
talked to ernest fitzgerald he's very
persuaded with what i had found he said
call robert perry this honest journalist
and i called you i left a message i
didn't get any response you never i
don't know if what happened with the
answering machine
but
information that contradicts what you've
said here is as near as the click of a
mouse
well i've looked at that issue and i
have since written 150 pages called
america's dreyfus affair
the case of the death of vincent foster
and i don't know if you looked at that
people can mail me if they think
anything i've said is wrong
they can email me
for nothing well well i've written about
this you've obviously seen my
my reporting on the website but
the uh i've looked at the vince foster
case and i've concluded that he died
pretty much as the other authorities
said he did that he committed suicide at
fort marcy park that there that none of
the other
uh supposed theories
can hold water
what what many people do is they they
get into the so-called anomaly situation
where they'll try to find the poke holes
and things but
no one has presented to me any serious
evidence that
that vince foster was murdered or that
he was killed or he died elsewhere and
was transported to fort marcy park
okay
you play right into the role of it it's
just conservatives it's just a bunch of
crazy right no no i just i know people
who are not conservative i'm not a
right-wing conservative i understand
that examine the evidence and i'll tell
you you're completely wrong well i've
examined the evidence too and if if
there was something there i would have
tried to say it but
yeah well did you read it yes i read the
star report you see the 20 page of denim
that went with it are you familiar with
that no i mean
you know what i'm talking about
well i just want to know are you
familiar with that
why is it that
okay all right
all right sir
well i'd like to title your books lost
history in my view
by the late 40s with the establishment
of the national security state history
became a commodity of the state
and not something that belonged to the
people in this country any longer
because they were able then to make
whole segments of what they were doing
secret
and to decide their policies behind
closed doors
i think the late 40s also dates a
beginning of a connection between
international drug trafficking and
covert operations
and specifically reactionary covert
operations or anti-communist operations
peter del scott mentions in cocaine
politics that in the 1980s there was a
meeting of the central american
anti-communist league
some of some of the most fascistic and
reactionary elements in
central america and that their general
strategy
that was developed at that meeting was
to use profits from
drug trade in their counter-insurgency
warfare
and throughout this the the role the oss
at the end of world war ii and then into
the role of cia up into the modern
period convinces me that the main source
of funding for covert operations has
been drugs
well
there's a good argument for what you say
the and clearly one of the problems that
the book addresses
is that we have had a half a century in
the united states of uh
of intense secrecy
the cold war was a period when much of
what might otherwise have been known to
us was kept from us
and it even goes back uh general
doolittle did a um report to president
eisenhower back in the early 50s i'm
sure you're familiar with where he said
that to engage in the cold war we will
have to deal with activities that would
be reprehensible to repugnant to
american values
and he suggested that that president
eisenhower
inform the american people of this
necessity
and try to convince them that we might
have to go by rules that americans would
not normally be proud of
the decision was effectively to go ahead
with the covert operations but not to
tell the american people to cut them out
uh and then to lie and cover up when
necessary so under that rubric of the
cold war a lot of secret and in many
ways criminal activities were permitted
and the united states became involved
with some very unsavory repugnant people
as general doolittle might have said
uh so so you had this you had that
problem and it went on for 50 years
and and and now that the cold war is
over
we're still being told basically that
we're not going to be given this
information there have been a few
outlets have been a few openings the
book talks about in guatemala for
instance just a year or so ago when the
when president clinton did grant did
release some of the material to the this
guatemalan truth commission and what
that truth commission came back with
based on u.s government documents was
extraordinary uh saying that 200 000
people had been killed in guatemala that
a genocide had been carried out against
the mayan indians
the the details is disturbing and
extraordinary uh there was also a report
that that a state department official
byron vakey wrote in 1968 he had been in
guatemala and came out and he wrote to
his superiors upon leaving
that that the united states was was
involved with
murderers that the united states was
tolerating and helping people engage in
torture and other methods that were not
part of the american spirit uh yet
that report like so much else was
stamped secret and hidden from the
american people for 30 years and when it
finally was released
this was in the midst of of course we
were in the midst of monica lewinsky at
the time as much as was happening during
monica lewinsky for over a year
that
the washington press corps could not
take a break
from the sex scandals to talk about
genocide that the united states was
implicated in
or about the cia's admissions
that its operatives were involved deeply
involved in the drug trade in in central
america during the 1980s the washington
press corps couldn't couldn't do that or
didn't do that uh so are your points
well taken that we and we do have this
whole era now uh almost a quarter of our
history
that has been essentially blacked out or
given to us in the most limited fashion
imaginable i often think that one of the
reasons that they won't release the cia
official budget is that it won't cover
their operations
yes sir
yes i'd like to ask uh follow up on some
of this other gentlemen brought about
the foster case i have looked into the
foster case and investigated it and i've
written a book uh called failure the
public trust fbicoverup.com and i quote
you in this book because my co-authors
thought you made some good points about
the failure of the washington press
corps but you're failing now because you
know
you're covering up a scandal now that we
don't want to wait 30 years for it to
come out
let me finish my question my question to
you is this if you go to the internet if
you go to fbicoverup.com
the american people can see for
themselves whether you're telling the
truth or whether i'm telling the truth
now the truth is that the facts are
there
it is a question the question is how can
you defend yourself
and you and your fellow journalists
when the truth is up on the internet i
mean you say you read the star report
but there was a 20 page of denim
attached with evidence of a cover-up you
seem to know nothing about it you can't
tell us about it but it comes
shrink-wrapped i ordered the star report
anybody can order it from the government
printing office they'll get the 20-page
addendum if you had introduced the
question
myself can you tell us about the 20
pages is that the question yes the
question is that just because
that a reporter's job is not to agree
with every argument that's made
a reporter's job is to evaluate the
evidence and i have looked at this much
more than probably i should i spent a
lot of time on this issue
and quite frankly i did it when i was
working for public broadcasting we were
doing a piece on the clinton scandals
and i went to the site i went through
much of the material and there was
fort marcy park but there is there is
simply no way
rationally
to explain how this could have happened
except as it was laid out by the fbi by
the county investigators by the park
police by star himself and and it's just
there's not a rational argument or or
any serious theory that's been put
forward of how it happened otherwise
and and
but that's my my answer is this is what
i looked at and i just i determined you
know you can disagree with me you're
part of the journalism problem
i would like to say
well what is the truth according to you
said the truth
heard is two different people and i
think there's probably three or four
more who've come to basically talk about
the vince foster case and and hammer
away at that okay so now
now we're going to now we have heard
let's talk about the airport now we've
heard about the vince foster story and
let's discuss some others
i would like to excuse me excuse me i
would like to arkansas i would like to
introduce brian barger who
is sitting over here brian um
is one of the one of the
great journalistic heroes of this era he
was uh a person who put his uh career
and
uh a lot of his uh
his reputation on the line to get at the
truth
um
who uh was instrumental in the in the
important reporting that the ap did
uh during this period in terms of both
uh telling the truth about the what was
going on with the contra war but also in
particular the the drug trafficking
problem uh and uh i would like to just
uh
note him he he uh he also worked for cnn
and um and other news organizations as
well but he's uh i i still think of him
as the guy that really was a key a key
figure in in getting all this
information out to the american people
so
anyway yes sir
hi um could you evaluate some of the
stories about chinese espionage i don't
know if you've looked at them if you
think that that's been overblown
somewhat and um on the monica lewinsky
scandal i was stunned that the media
dropped it as soon as there were
allegations that there was a third
country with
tapes of
um uh
clinton's
uh conversations with monica lewinsky
that as soon as it might have actually
hit a real issue
uh it was dropped i don't know if there
was any credence to those allegations if
you could comment on that as well
well you know there's
i'm not an expert on everything in the
world i'm sorry the um i wish i were but
um
obviously the
the i would look at the whole question
of the clinton scandals somewhat
differently than other people have i
think
we saw coming out of this this period of
the 1980s and early 90s not just the the
kinds of factual issues we're talking
here but there was there was a there was
another element here which was an effort
to control the media
and and part of the book deals with the
present so-called project truth and and
parallel to these problems in with the
contras and with other intelligence
activities
there was an effort by the cia at least
by the director william casey working
through the national security council in
a so-called public diplomacy team at the
state department to get the president
aligned
and many of us were subjected to a lot
of attacks some people lost jobs
uh to try to try to get the washington
press corps not to be as independent as
it had been in the 70s
and this sort of goes on through the
through the 80s and into the early 90s
uh effectively this was a way to protect
the reagan bush presidencies as well
there was a great deal of concern among
the conservatives after after nixon's uh
uh forced resignation in over watergate
and then
the loss of the vietnam war and the
exposures of the cia offenses during the
mid 70s so there was a reason for this
kind of effort to get control of the
washington press corps
i think much of this though continued
and when president clinton got into
office
uh
that machinery that had been set up much
of it now in in conservative magazines
conservative newspapers conservative
radio talk shows and so forth
much of it just turned on him
this is not to say that there aren't
things that that president clinton did
that really deserve
serious criticism it is to say that many
of them were exaggerated
and just and i would argue that what we
saw in the disinformation or the efforts
to
the so-called perception management as
it was called back in the 80s
uh
just continued on into the 90s with an
effort to contain whatever
projects that president clinton might
have had i think
the republicans have reached a point i
think after almost controlling the
presidency for nearly a quarter century
except for jimmy carter's four-year
interregnum
that that they
really own the white house it was their
territory
and i think they were quite upset about
losing it and i think that a lot of what
we we've seen in terms of some of these
very
uh i would say minor scandals being made
into major ones travel for the travel
office affair for instance or or
filegate
there was a real effort to magnify those
just as there was an effort to minimize
the scandals during the 80s which i
think were far more serious when you're
talking about uh human rights violations
and drug trafficking and so forth now so
i think that's colored how this is all
gone and certainly i think it may be a
point that there may have been more
serious questions raised in connection
with the monica lewinsky affair but i do
think you know after a whole year of
dealing with it the probably the press
probably was a little tired
uh and clearly was not going to go to
the full
conviction of president clinton
in the senate so there probably was a
little backing away and maybe there
should have been some more attention to
a few of these points but i think there
was a great deal of effort to get it
everything possible about president
clinton in terms of from whitewater on
through some of the minor scandals
through his impeachment
yes miss
mr perry i must say i have been an
admirer of yours for many years
in particular i remember one article
that you wrote back in 1996
concerning the salvadoran situation
and uh a reporter from the new york
times mr bonner
who had actually caught a u.s green
beret pretending going along in a patrol
with the salvadoran army
then when mr bonner wrote about it uh
the green berets produced massive
numbers of um
witnesses i remember that variable by
the way i miss it on your webpage i went
to your web page today i couldn't find
it there i request that you put that
back up there again well it should be
there but might you know things happen
okay just want to let you know i'm a
longtime fan
and um i think it's marvelous what
you've done in exposing the covert and
illegal actions the u.s has taken
overseas i'm a little concerned about
your record
on exposing the u.s illegal and covert
actions that take place on u.s soil
in particular i'm concerned about the
article that you have on your website
not written by you but obviously
endorsed by you by molly dickerson on
waco
in fact
there is massive evidence that's
publicly available
that shows waco was overwhelmingly
a
military intelligence event i have here
something that i downloaded from the
waco holocaust electronic museum
the public documents there's no
conspiracy theory in it it's government
issue
now if you have a look at this material
it's very obvious
that the waco raid of february 28 1993
was nothing more or less than designed
to fail
it was a domestic gulf of tonkin
incident yet miss dickerson in the
article that you're hosting now on the
web page
pretends the raid was a failed law
enforcement exercise
she even
makes the most laughable statements
that
the davidians ambushed the batf
well i think that was based on the on
the on the
report that the
that there had been that the davidians
were aware that the that uh the atf
people were on their way
but i think the point of that article is
that there's a great deal of blame to go
everywhere it was look would you have a
look and i'll bring these up to you this
is the medical the the um
this is the military equipment on hand
at day one
this was
you're you're you're talking about these
tanks
and storm troopers you're talking about
helicopters shooting into the building
on day one
going around excuse me but the story but
the story
said that the there was well it said
well i didn't say anything but the story
said
the story the story said that there was
uh there was an uh an excessive
application of force and in the earliest
raid
this is this is a military invasion on
u.s citizens living peacefully in their
own home sir i'm just concerned that
you've taken a dive on this issue it
breaks my heart well i don't think we
have but these are hard these are hard
stories it's not that none of them come
easily
well i'd be happy to look at it
i've looked at a great deal of this
material go ahead say anyone else
anything on central america i have a
question about the kosovo war and i'm
only asking this because i've seen
articles that you've written about it so
i don't really think it's off topic
and in your book you do criticize the
press for being too
docile on on everything basically
and uh
well i noticed that you had criticized
president clinton somewhat on what you i
believe you referred to it as an info
war
but
i didn't read anywhere where you
actually
questioned the
legitimacy
of u.s and nato involvement in the war
itself
and
so i would like to ask do you believe
the atrocities committed by the serbs
against the albanians in kosovo were
comparable to those committed by the
nazis against the jews
in world war ii in germany and as an
aside what is your opinion about
prominent and respected world war ii
historian david irving's harassment and
subsequent lawsuit because of his claim
that after 10 years of research in the
german archives he found no evidence
whatsoever of a nazi master plan to
exterminate jews and gas chambers
well
i think the
on the question of kosovo um
we have written we wrote a number of
stories that are the news by the way the
website is consortiumnews.com so people
want to actually see what we've we've
wrote they can look at it but the uh
in in kosovo we wrote i think a fairly
balanced approach we uh we were critical
of of of the way president clinton uh
tried to sell the war in kosovo we uh we
talked about how uh how he did not
present the history of the situation as
fully as he should have he did make a
one-sided presentation to the american
people and that that obviously in the
sense of being a journalist you have to
be critical when someone doesn't give
the whole story and we were we also we
had a piece about the bombing of the the
television station uh in belgrade and
raising questions about that i did a lot
did a long piece about clinton's
approval of so-called information
warfare
um against the against yugoslavia it
didn't actually end up i think being
very effective but the idea was to use
high-tech computer
means to uh to penetrate into the
computer systems of yugoslavia and and
disrupt them
we actually we had an interest there was
a document that i came upon
written in the pentagon for people who
were who were needed to be needed to
know about this these procedures but
weren't really directly involved it was
called information warfare for dummies
and and the report in in that sort of
very light-hearted way describes the us
capabilities
of planting viruses and enemy computer
systems and and disrupting information
flows um information warfare has become
sort of the hot topic inside the
pentagon and inside the intelligence
community
but is very little discussed
in the washington press corps other than
the us being threatened by it by by
hackers from overseas but we have tried
to deal i think thoroughly with that we
and we did write about some of the
atrocities too by the by the uh by the
serb forces so
uh it is difficult especially when
you're a small operation as we are
without much resources to to to get the
kind of firsthand information you'd like
to have
my question is do you believe that the
atrocities occurred with the intensity
and the magnitude that that the
mainstream news media said that it that
it did which i don't believe that there
were i certainly i would not compare the
atrocities in
uh in kosovo with uh
the the atrocities during world war ii
i'm just curious do you have any comment
about david irving because i've been
hearing his name on c-span on national
public radio all this week i haven't
read that of that book
yes sorry yeah so sorry um can you tell
us something about how the internet um
is changing the way
news is
um
the way the news is getting out to
people um and whether
it will have what kind of effect it will
have over a long period
or even a short term period
well we started uh consortiumnews.com as
a website back in 1995
and there wasn't much there at the time
really i think salon started about the
same time we did
um
uh they've had uh they've had more money
than we've had but the um but i do think
that the internet has the potential to
allow
uh more diverse points of view to be to
be presented to the public
uh the problem is that as we were seeing
the internet is really evolving into uh
into a shopping mall like an electronic
shopping mall
and the major internet sites
um are pretty much the same as the
mainstream television operations or
print operations so you have
nbc with msnbc and msnbc.com i guess is
the largest
the one that's the most trafficked for
any website and we're seeing basically
the internet become more and more like
uh conventional journalism with both the
good and the bad of that
and i think the major
internet operatives like aol are
increasingly moving in that direction as
we saw with the with the merger with
time warner
so i think the the the people that think
the internet will be a panacea and sort
of refresh democracy in a thorough way
are are being a little too hopeful um
it can help
that more can be done in terms of
providing diverse points of view but
i don't think it's going to
be the cure-all
brian
yeah i
don't have a specific question i want to
make a couple of comments i hope that
that's not going to get me into trouble
all right
um
i think that your book is is excellent
and as i think your previous book
fooling america is also a very very
important contribution to our
understanding of
what was going on during the 1980s
you and i spent several years in the
trenches trying to dig out the truth in
the face of
forces that we did not understand and
frankly i was in a state of of disbelief
largely as i was going through
investigating
people like oliver north i could not
believe that a top official in the white
house would be involved in some of the
things that we were learning about
i couldn't believe that cia officials
would be recruiting known drug
traffickers to go down as early as 1983
to central america
to support a war that did not have
public support in the united states to
bolster them because bill casey was
convinced these guys were losers and and
didn't know how to fight a war
that
institutionalized a relationship between
drug trafficking and anti-communism
um and there are
there's a lot of evidence going back
decades
of us government officials
not just turning a blind eye
but under the guise of of
the ends justifies the means
finding whoever it is who necessary to
accomplish their goal which was fighting
communism whether that meant allying
themselves with
terrorists murderers
rapists with drug traffickers
it really didn't matter i mean what the
cia kept telling you and me is well you
can't expect us to all be just hiring
boy scouts we'd never get our work done
i mean that was the common line that
we'd always get on the phone and that
was about as far as they would ever
comment
um
i think that what you have done
in these recent years with your books
which i think is such a significant
contribution
is to point out how important it is to
document history
today history is written by the people
in power
and
if we relied on the likes of the new
york times and the washington post
to
tell and document history for us
i think there would be very little
understanding of what took place in the
1980s
the united states government was
involved in
numerous
criminal activities
um
condoning
protecting people who were involved in
wholesale massacres
ongoing human rights violations
drug trafficking was one part of it but
hundreds of thousands of people lost
their lives
during this war in the name of
ideology
um and
you helped put that into perspective and
the way that you did it was because
you're such a good investigative
reporter
i mean since the day we met i've always
respected you for your ability to
always be pursuing the facts and being
able to put those facts together and
follow an evidence trail and i think
that that's the
a brilliant contribution that you have
made to this and i think that titling
this book lost history
is as appropriate as the title to your
last book on on fooling america which
was about this entire campaign a
government-wide campaign to that they
called public diplomacy
which was based on
this notion of bill casey's that came
from i think his days in marketing and
on madison avenue that if you can if you
repeat a lie enough times that people
will eventually believe it and that's
the way the whole public relations
apparatus and the us government worked
and you and i were
subjected to that on an ongoing basis so
i just wanted to commend you for your
great work but it wasn't just us i mean
the problem was that uh reporters across
the board in washington came under this
pressure and some of the stories of
people reporters you've probably never
heard of who had tried to do their job
and ended up
uh finding their careers damaged or
ended
was fairly was was not uncommon at all
in washington during this era i was in
when i was covering a story in haiti um
uh back in 93 i i had a chance to have
dinner with a woman reporter um who had
was one of brian and my real competitors
she was at reuters in honduras at the
time
and she described
the problems women reporters had in
particular because this central america
was the first war that women reporters
really covered in a serious way for in
the united states
and they were particularly susceptible
to these kind of whisper campaigns that
the the embassies the u.s embassies in
the area or the state department here
would start about them having sexual
relations with sandinistas and that sort
of thing and the women wouldn't even
know about these things and they were
being accused of this unless they might
something something might have been
blurted out to them and there was really
no way for them to defend themselves but
it was those kind of techniques that we
saw across the board in washington
during the 80s very
there was a kind of siege mentality on
this issue and and
and brian um
uh was subjected to a lot of it as uh as
with people like ray bonner the new york
times and others
anyway yes sir
can you talk a little bit about the the
economics of your website and also
uh i think since you uh your website
published this book as well correct well
yeah my company did yeah um and just
just how you uh how you make a living
well not we don't make a lot of money
i've got to say
i do jobs you know i do other work along
the side when people want uh wants
something done but
uh the website of course isn't very
expensive uh the expense goes into the
journalism
um and we do sell um uh print versions
uh and that has raised us some money and
we do you know solicit from our readers
if they have extra money they want to
send us we certainly we certainly
welcome it
but um
but it has not been particularly um it's
we have not shown this is a particularly
viable financial model at this point
you're not getting rich
um let's have questions for people who
haven't had a chance at that yes sir
yeah mr perry you said that um
at least in so far as the drug
trafficking is concerned that there was
a failure of the independent council uh
lawrence walsh uh there was a failure of
the press
um
and there was a failure of the congress
now the
sort of the same
thing is happening in a
civil rights case that i'm prosecuting
in the district here and i emailed you
and told you about it one of these other
gentlemen already mentioned it's the the
information is at fbicoverup.com
now you emailed me back
um and i could tell by your email
without going to the specifics that you
really hadn't had an opportunity uh to
read a copy of the book that i have here
with me that i gave you that was filed
in federal court so my question is very
quick
will you read it and will you
um
uh give me some feedback uh when you get
an opportunity to yeah i should read the
entire book i read i read sections of
that i mean i don't have all the time in
the world to look at everything and i've
spent a lot of time on the vince foster
case
and my conclusions are
that he that he died
by his own hand with a gun in the park
and
and i have not seen any coherent
explanation or serious evidence of
anything else and that includes what i
what i read in in in that book you sent
me so i'm not going to say something i
don't believe i'm not going to say i'm
not going to pretend that there's a
there's something more sinister here
when my reporting finds that there isn't
what's the most persuasive evidence okay
look we've had enough on the vince
foster case
not going to beat a dead horse to them
um
if there's a question on someone
something else we will be happy with the
guy over there talk for another 10
minutes about nothing
beg your pardon
okay well yes gentlemen
well let me just add that even can stars
at last
going all over the tube saying that it
was indeed a suicide there's no question
about it
and um what's the most persuasive
evidence he presents do you think
look i really don't even even vince
foster's family accepted it the day it
happened this gentleman in the back
excuse me excuse me this gentleman in
the back i'd just like to uh
make a comment on
the uh
the mainstream press
um i worked about 10 years ago 12 years
ago whatever it was in l.a for a group
called the cristic institute which at
that time was pretty well known
and
since it's you know forgotten history
and at that time
we would put on forums and we invited a
journalist and professor to talk about
what was going on in
in iran iraq the iraq war he had written
for the new york times and he was the
head of a journalism department he told
me one time that well he had knew
central american well very well
that uh he called them and said what's
you know why aren't you guys covering
this christic institute lawsuit which
was going after the very same people
that you've been talking about from the
80s
and he says
that he called this friend of his on the
new york times
the guy told him
you will never see the name kristic
institute in the new york times
uh and i think they didn't actually
mention the name chris against the new
york times but in a derisive way
um
i think the new york times did a very
bad job on on the contra drug problem
and exactly why i can't really tell you
uh but essentially as this was
developing the new york times was way
behind the curve
um they didn't uh understand the the
dimensions there were the reporters they
assigned to it were not capable i think
of getting the story
uh they wrote stories that were
blatantly untrue i mean there was a
piece as i mentioned earlier and it was
87 which said that there was no mention
of contra drug trafficking anywhere
until after the iran contra scandal
broke which was in november of 86 when
the story that brian barger and i wrote
at ap appeared in
december of 85 almost a year earlier and
they said that their the only
allegations came from convicted drug
dealers which isn't true either
why the new york times took that
position that defensive position on
behalf of the us government you know i
can't really speak to i wasn't inside
the new york times at that point but i
know there was a lot of pressure from
the from the public diplomacy apparatus
at the state department
uh this organization that william casey
was overseeing out of the cia
that there was this effort to intimidate
the press and it was very successful
i think a lot of reporters saw a real
chance to lose their careers if they
pursued those stories and chose not to
okay okay should we yes i think uh i
want to thank you all for coming i i
want to thank you bob i think what
you're doing is
valiant and important and even if you um
can't cover all the issues of the world
so thank you very much for presenting
your book today and we look forward to
your new magazine thanks all for coming
robert perry has been a member of the
washington press corps for 22 years
lost history is published by the media
consortium
online at consortiumnews.com
[Music]